another bombshell sexual harassment
allegation rocks capitol hill this time
a sitting senator is the accused al
franken a Democrat from Minnesota has
apologized after a woman came forward
with damning accusations today leon
tweeted a news anchor at a radio station
in l.a accuses the senator of harassing
and groping her when they were on a USO
tour together in 2006 before Franken was
a member of Congress and she has some
proof she posted this picture along with
a column titled senator Al Franken
kissed and groped me without my consent
and there's nothing funny about it here
is more from tweetIn he came at me and
before I even knew it he he grabbed the
he put his hand on the back of my head
and came towards me and and mashed his
face against my mouth and and stuck his
tongue in my mouth and you know I sort
of pushed him back and I said don't ever
do that to me again and I was so angry
and I walked out of there Franken
doesn't deny some of the allegations
along with his apology he said this in a
statement I respect women I don't
respect men who don't I don't know what
was in my head when I took that picture
and it doesn't matter there is no excuse
I look at it now and I feel disgusted
with myself it isn't funny it's
completely inappropriate senator
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell has
called for an ethics committee
investigation of Franken and so has the
senator himself he says he will gladly
cooperate a second accuser named Melanie
Morgan also came forward today alleging
Franken harassed her years ago all right
indeed a rapidly developing story Greg
because we have two accusations now and
also proof we talking about this
yesterday with the juxtaposition of Roy
Moore and people wanting okay let's do a
full due process investigation find out
what's going on she's come forward the
proof a picture they say is worth a
thousand words yeah I have to say I know
I know Leeanne going way back she's a
good friend of mine used to read I all
the time she once gave me combat boots
for Christmas so she's no snowflake so
clearly this kind of thing was way
on her for a while and an epicenter and
you you know you look at the picture of
my first quest my first thing okay
that's you know it's humiliating because
you don't know that it's happening but
if he's touching her then that's actual
assault but I can't tell if he's
touching her or not but regardless it is
a humiliating thing that somebody's
doing something without your knowledge
and of course that's separate from what
else he did when he forced a kiss from
her in the green room which I happened
to think she's telling the truth because
look what we're seeing there mike-mike
sense is that there's gonna be more of
these stories and they're gonna affect
all occupations and the I think that
there needs to be some kind of process
and one of the one of the encouraging
things out of this one that I see is
that she came forward with this he
apologized she accepted his apology
which I find it's kind of interesting
could this be the start of a new process
in dealing with these problems because
right now in the realm of public opinion
everything's equal all men are created
equal but not all accusations are equal
we have no way of prioritizing what is
severe and what is stupid and and and I
think there has to be a process for this
other than just saying like we're all
putting all of this stuff in the same
file does that make sense I guess I
don't know Jillian buddy what do you
think about that in terms of saying
there has to be a process and perhaps
this is a new sort of template or
framework for how people can go forward
you make the accusation you have the
proof the person apologized where do you
go from there and what do you think
about this story well I think the more
cases where you have a perpetrator who
acknowledges what happened and then
apologized apologizes if the victim can
personally forgive them then that is the
password it doesn't matter what the rest
of the general public thinks it's
incumbent upon the woman who is
victimized or the person who is
victimized to come to terms with that a
quick point on the macro picture here is
I think all of this stuff from Bill
Cosby years ago through Harvey Weinstein
Roy Moore Al Franken this moment really
highlights that I think the harassment
of women and assault of women is not
just a women's issue it's something that
the entire American population has to
grapple with
and it's also certainly not a political
issue too often lately we turn to
focusing on the perpetrators identity
and their politics and that does a
disservice to everybody because this is
not a political issue
rape victims assault victims I really
don't think care whether the
perpetrators are liberals or
conservatives Republicans or Democrats
this is a much more important issue it
sort of transcends politics and I think
our discussion it's not just like here
at the table but the American discourse
should reflect that okay on a more macro
level I think yes macro level yeah and I
think these are examples in these cases
of people who have suffered and the
victims and the allegations they make
you know we study them we listen we
learn and then like Greg said it perhaps
it provides a framework going forward
and it's educational Jesse so people
understand that you know this is not
acceptable
absolutely and he should be held
accountable which I believe he will be
and the initial apology if anybody read
it was really bad he trivialized it and
said something along the lines of you
know I'm really sorry that she
misremembered it or remembered it
differently than I did and then acted
like it was a skit that was done in poor
taste the second apology was much better
and she accepted it so there's no
lawsuit there's an accepted apology Greg
makes a great point because we're
putting pedophilia allegedly drugging
women raping women exposing yourself in
a basket of a grow or a kiss or
something like that unwanted and you
know it the whole thing's a mess so
Franken has supported victims of sexual
assault throughout his career which
makes him a hypocrite but it also for
the left makes them more reluctant to
hang the guy now sending Franken to the
Senate Ethics Committee is a complete
whitewash the ethics committee cannot do
a good job they're not transparent
there's no accountability there's only
been one action taken by the Senate
Ethics Committee in the last five years
and it was a sternly worded letter to
some senator so the Senate can't police
himself that's one thing in Congress
needs to get off its high horse because
Congress like the rest of the
institutions of this kind
has a problem with sexual harassment
they've settled I believe 260 cases
since the late 90s of sexual harassment
and discrimination to the tune of 15
million dollars that's over ten
settlements per year that's our money we
don't know who settled these cases we
have a right to know since we're paying
for it so I'd like to see what those
results are all right get back to Jessie
okay Juan so what do you think of the
allegations you know today what happened
and also just get your thoughts on how
Senator Franken reacted to them well I
think he reacted pretty well especially
when he apologized I think that was
appropriate and you know the thing about
it is that this was on some USO tour I'm
not sure what's going on between
entertainers and the like but what was
clear and I think this is picking up on
when Greg said if she felt that somehow
he had crossed the line then he she
deserves an apology should be clear that
in doing her job she does not have to
put up with that kind of foolishness so
what I would say to you Kimberly that
this comes in an atmosphere that really
is at the moment Harvey Weinstein and
now Roy Moore down Alabama the political
context is so important for us at this
moment and in that context we see things
like the Liberals and I'll speak to that
as the Democrat here liberals saying hey
you know what we should have paid
attention to Bill Clinton oh my gosh a
writer for the Box a writer for the New
York Times saying you know I'm going
back and I'm looking back on this and I
believe Juanita Broderick and all the
rest so and I think to myself and why is
this going on why is the left doing this
I think the left is doing this because
they fear that Republicans the
Conservatives will say hey you didn't go
after your guys but you want to go after
Judge more and therefore you're a
hypocrite how dare you do this let's get
the judge more thank you once but can I
finish this point oh yes sure
so but my point to you is I think that
when you look at what's going on on the
right with judge Moore at the moment you
see the same kind of I don't know what
you angst or upset President Trump today
can't say a word not say a word
guess what Steve Bannon still can't say
a word but Drudge says Steve Bannon with
note then Breitbart cause language says
fake news coming from Drudge no Steve
Bannon is not abandoning Roy Moore and
we see in the polls Moore's numbers
going down but I don't see any big
change in terms of the Republican Party
establishment on Moore and I think
Republicans in some extent are
delighting in the troubles that now
beset Al Franken say oh this is
equivalent well - again Greg's point
this ain't equivalent all right well
while I was going to you on this
embattled Republican Senate hopeful Roy
Moore appeared before cameras today and
he vowed to remain in the Alabama race
and watch Senate Majority Leader's took
go this is an effort by Mitch McConnell
and his cronies to steal this election
from the people of Alabama and they will
not stand for it well I want to tell you
who needs to step down
that's Mitch McConnell I'll quit
standing when they lay me in that box
and put me in the ground the White House
weighed in on the more controversy
earlier does the president believe Roy
Moore's accusers of us who think Roy
Moore to drop this race but the
President believes that these
allegations are very troubling and
should be taken seriously and he thinks
that the people of Alabama should make
the decision on who their next senator
should be look I'm not gonna get into
and litigate back and forth but the
president's been clear that if any of
these allegations are true allegations
that he takes very seriously finds very
troubling if those do happen to be true
then he should do the right thing and
step aside okay so find the White House
issuing a statement on this I think that
when it comes to more I said this
yesterday but I really meant it like the
writing's on the wall you know Lindsey
Graham said the other day to the press I
think he needs to step down step aside
for the good of himself his family and
the state I think what he really meant
though was he needs to step aside for
the good of the Republican Party sure
because there is no good solution here
for the party
having a sitting senator if he wins
having a sitting senator who's plagued
by allegations of sexual misconduct is a
nightmare and I think that also having a
Senate that votes that if he wins and
the Senate votes to expel him with the
two-thirds majority vote that's even
worse in a sense because then he become
the first senator since like the Civil
War since the 19th century to be
expelled and the first one ever to be
expelled for these kinds of charges so
it's just he's an albatross around the
GOP his neck at this point alright just
real quick how quickly blond said that
the Republican establishment really is
not doing much with more every single
Republican senator has pulled their
endorsement of more and all of the money
from the RNC and the Senate Republican
Conference that's tried up to say that
there's been no movement there is just
wrong now more as being selfish to hang
in here
the guy's got to go obviously even if
Donald Trump himself said mores gotta go
I think more might still stay in there
one also brought up the Clinton
situation and that's interesting because
I'd like to talk about that multiple
women had consensual affairs with Bill
Clinton that's not the issue
it was the Juanita Broderick accusation
of rape she actually had a friend who
said afterwards she saw her with a
bloody mouth and she was rattled you had
a settlement with Paula Jones for almost
a million dollars for sexual harassment
and then Kathleen Wiley said she was
groped in the White House now right now
you don't see Republicans trying to
destroy the accusers personally in the
Alabama situation yet during those whole
when the women came through with these
allegations against Bill Clinton Hillary
Clinton herself called Monica a
narcissistic loony tune Hillary Clinton
called Jennifer flowers a failed cabaret
singer and James Carville famously said
of Gennifer Flowers dragged a hundred
dollar bill through a trailer park
you never know you'll find
Stephanopoulos even said these are just
bimbos remember the whole bimbo eruption
and you had Gloria Steinem feminist icon
defend Bill Clinton apologize to Anita
Braga
she did a lot of people say that's too
little too late but I'm glad she found
misunderstood what I was saying to you I
would never do the Republican
establishment in fact as Mitch McConnell
and people like Mitch McConnell and the
Senators who have all condemned Roy
Moore so that's not what I'm talking I'm
talking about people like Steve banning
the reluctance on the part of President
did say right so this is where you see
that there are people including in the
state of Alabama the Alabama
a Republican party that is reluctant to
say you know what we've got a problem
this is damaging as Jillian said to the
Republican brand it's people who are in
the so-called Republican establishment
who see that broader picture and say you
know what you might have a grievance
against the media you might have a
grievance against the Liberals but this
is damaging to the GOP I think I got to
go to this larger point that is bigger
than then what's happening with more
Frank and the media has yes yet to
discern differences in scale right in
the court of public opinion we are this
is now officially allegation nation and
we lack the deliberate body to assess
matters so it's gonna come and it's
gonna hurt everybody unless we learn to
find out find a process that says when
the allegation happens instead of it
being followed by media hysteria that
there is some kind of deliberate way of
assessing it and I think I mean the what
you're seeing with the Franken is at
least the beginning of something because
you saw him you she came out with it he
responds she accepts it I don't know
where it goes from there b-but but at
least it's something
seems like progress I don't know it's a
big difference between that though and
messing with a fourteen years that's
what I'm talking about but then but then
my point is this it's all put in the
same file its George Bush George Herbert
Walker Bush has just got accused again
for grabbing a woman's yes and and and
and you see that that's lumped in Dustin
Hoffman was accused of something I think
something creepy to an intern that's
lumped in we're great yeah we meet you
crazy yeah we're we're in the media
we're throwing it all into one pot
stirring it up
all right well after that discussion you
may not know that